puisqu'on parle de solutions mais le
climat j'aimerais souligner l'initiative
du jour de la terre de plants et 375
mille arbres à montréal donc je vous
invite à aller voir leur site web de
donner 10 dollars pour acheter un arbre
je pense qu'un juste assez important
l'université mémorial aussi qu' un
projet aussi de planter des arbres pour
décontaminer du terrain on a beaucoup de
terrains contaminés un moyen qui sont
inutilisés donc pourquoi pas planter des
arbres sur ses terres et nos pour
décontaminer un terrain qui ne vaut rien
en ce moment puisqu'ils décontaminer qui
coûterait une fortune à décontaminer
donc en dix ans il pourrait être
totalement décontaminer que je dis
souvent et en même temps apporter
plusieurs valeurs foncières etc a aussi
aidé beaucoup les îlots de chaleur on
n'a pas parlé beaucoup du lot de
challans aussi c'est un aspect important
qu'il faudrait parler j'aimerais ça au
cirad en attente mais c'est pas si rots
et les chercheurs qui s'y font partie du
sirop de là on est pas faire attention
façon de le dire on s'intéresse beaucoup
à ce verdissement urbain là et le lien à
faire avec la santé mais en fait avec
toute l'ailé les hyperliens qu'on peut
faire avec les îlots de chaleur avec
l'agriculture urbaine avec la qualité de
l'air avec le fait que c'est agréable
d'être entourée d'arbres
on a juste à se promener dans les rues
de montréal quand que des armes pilotes
comme en ce moment qu'un cas ne
t'inquiète pas de feuille c'est pas le
même montréal qu'on connaît donc vers du
semeur ben oui faut miser là-dessus faut
juste par contre faire attention pas
faire les mêmes gars qu'on a déjà fait
quand on est déjà fait dans le passé
avec les chaînes et qu'on a fait
actuellement avec les freine c'est à
dire de reboiser seulement une espèce
surtout avec les changements climatiques
parce que tout ce qui est éco systèmes
écosystémiques est en train de se
déplacer
ça a même des parasites ça amène que
l'on risque de pu avoir darbas montréal
à cause qu'on a à boiser reboiser
seulement avec une espèce inondant la
biodiversité